so what I've said so Far doesn't
guarantee anything about the existence
of limit where newton's conant is
actually Infinity but nevertheless that
limit May exist If that limit exists
that limit the limiting Theory is a
Theory in 11 dimensions it'll be a su
symmetric relativistic Theory in 11
dimensions with 11 dimensional
supergravity is Slow Energy limit and
depending on no dimensionless parameters
does it exist I haven't the faintest
idea
[Música]
Hola hoy en Science le la teoría
m sabemos describir nuestro universo con
dos teorías la relatividad general que
modeliza la gravedad a gran escala
utilizando el espacio tiempo curvo y el
modelo estándar de partículas que
unifica todas las demás interacciones
con Campos cuánticos cuyas vibraciones
pueden interpretarse como
partículas estos dos modelos son
bastante similares ambos explotan el
concepto de campo el campo de la
curvatura del espacio-tiempo para la
relatividad general y los campos
cuánticos de las partículas para el
modelo
estándar pero mientras que la
relatividad es una teoría clásica dice
una evolución precisa en el tiempo el
modelo estándar es cuántico describe el
mundo mediante superposiciones y
probabilidades estas dos teorías
describen dos universos completamente
diferentes la relatividad general Es una
excelente descripción de nuestro
universo pero cuando nos acercamos a la
materia Tenemos que tener en cuenta los
fenómenos de la física
cuántica podemos describir describir las
perturbaciones de la curvatura del
espacio-tiempo como un campo cuántico
cuyas fluctuaciones pueden verse como
partículas los
gravitones de este modo podemos
determinar el comportamiento cuántico de
la
gravedad pero si nos acercamos a menos
de una quintillones ima de micrómetro
por debajo de la escala de plank los
cálculos ya no dan resultado la gravedad
ya no parece compatible con el mundo
cuántico
Cómo conciliar losos Cómo entender lo
que ocurre allí donde la gravedad actúa
a escala fundamental como en el centro
de los agujeros negros o en los primeros
instantes del Big Bang vamos a
sumergirnos en el mundo abstracto de la
física teórica en busca de un candidato
prometedor para resolver este problema
la teoría
m atención se trata de un tema
especialmente abstracto y es mejor haber
visto antes el video sobre la teoría de
[Música]
cuerdas es la década de los 70 y los
investigadores se interesan por una
teoría prometedora la supergravedad
nuestro espacio tiempo tiene cuatro
simetrías la física no cambia después de
traslaciones rotaciones el paso de
tiempo y cambios de marcos de referencia
estas cuatro simetrías están incluidas
temáticamente en la relatividad general
pero podría existir otra simetría aún
hipotética llamada supersimetría
si incluimos también esta simetría
obtenemos la supergravedad
la supergravedad es muy similar a la
relatividad el espaciotiempo puede
curvarse generar estructuras
interesantes incluso producir
singularidades adimensionales que forman
agujeros
negros pero los físicos se divierten
explorándolos
hipotéticos con más dimensiones y la
teoría predice entonces generalizaciones
de agujeros negros con una dos o más
dimensiones formando objetos extendidos
membranas o branas para
abreviar pueden tener masa carga e
incluso ser supers
simétricas el modelo es interesante pero
una vez más los cálculos fallan Más allá
de la escala de
blan como ocurre con la relatividad la
supergravedad no funciona a escala
[Música]
fundamental sin embargo en la década de
los 80 los físicos descubrieron un nuevo
modelo
revolucionario supone que todas las
partículas estaban formadas por una
pequeña hebra vibrante de energía una
cuerda a aprovechando también el
concepto de supersimetría se conoce como
teoría de las supercuerdas
cuando se encuentran las cuerdas pueden
interactuar entre sí combinarse o
dividirse y como la cuerda de una
guitarra pueden adoptar diferentes modos
de vibración que se comportan a nuestra
escala como partículas
diferentes nos quedamos atónitos al
descubrir que uno de estos modos de
vibración se comporta Exactamente igual
que el graviton esta teoría permite por
primera vez describir la gravedad
cuántica de forma
fundamental el modelo es prometedor pero
impone restricciones al universo la
teoría impone que el espacio tiempo no
tenga cuatro sino 10 dimensiones con
seis dimensiones espaciales que nunca se
han detectado hasta ahora la teoría
también establece los tipos de cuerdas
que pueden estudiarse si por ejemplo
decidimos estudiar cuerdas abiertas
pueden cerrarse sobre sí mismas por lo
que también hay que estudiar cuerdas
cerradas con estas restricciones Los
investigadores descubrieron que la
teoría solo permite cinco tipos de
universo el tipo uno que contiene
cuerdas abiertas y cerradas los tipos 2a
y 2b que contienen cuerdas cerradas y
dos tipos
E2 y e8 Cruz e8 que contienen cuerdas
cerradas con diferentes tipos de
vibraciones en direcciones
opuestas son las únicas variaciones
posibles para describir nuestro universo
con supercuerdas En cuál de estas cinco
versiones vivimos cuál describe
realmente nuestro
universo dejemos esta cuestión de lado y
volvamos a la supergravedad
[Música]
se podría pensar que la teoría de
supercuerdas y la supergravedad son dos
descripciones separadas en realidad
existe un vínculo íntimo entre ellas a
gran escala ambas describen un universo
supers simétrico con gravedad Y con
razón la supergravedad si se aplica a un
Universo de 10 dimensiones Resulta ser
una aproximación de la teoría de
supercuerdas
esto implica que las branas de la
supergravedad también existen en el
mundo de las
cuerdas las cuerdas son solo uno de los
tipos posibles de branas
unidimensionales pero también existen
las d branas a las que se pueden unir
cuerdas abiertas y las ns5 branas que
son de cinco
dimensiones por tanto la supergravedad
sigue sio siendo útil y los
investigadores han descubierto otra
propiedad inesperada la supergravedad
solo acepta un número máximo de 11
dimensiones una más que en la teoría de
supercuerdas
en este modelo de 11 dimensiones todas
las constantes del universo estarían
establecidas por las
matemáticas A diferencia de las cinco
variaciones de la teoría de supercuerdas
la supergravedad nos ofrece una nueva y
única teoría para describir el mundo en
11 dimensiones al menos como
aproximación en resumen a principios de
los años 90 disponíamos de un panel de
seis modelos matemáticos interesantes
las cinco versiones de la teoría de
supercuerdas con 10 dimensiones y la
supergravedad con 11
dimensiones pero varios investigadores
en particular Edward wht descubrieron
poco poco a poco una red de conexiones
sutiles dualidades que unían entre sí
todas estas
teorías los físicos empezaron estudiando
la supergravedad de 11 dimensiones Este
modelo contiene entre otras cosas branas
bidimensionales pero imaginemos
transformar una de las 11 dimensiones en
un círculo y reducirla hasta que deje de
ser visible solo quedan 10 dimensiones y
las branas perdido una dimensión
convirtiéndose en
cuerdas sorprendentemente el modelo
resultante se comporta como la teoría de
las supercuerdas o más exactamente como
su versión
2a antes del descubrimiento de esta
dualidad Los investigadores solo podían
estudiar las supercuerdas con cuerdas
que interactuaban muy poco entre sí el
enfoque utilizado para calcular su
comportamiento perturba Evo consiste en
tomar tomar una estimación inicial y
añadirle pequeñas correcciones para
calcular las interacciones de forma cada
vez más
precisa pero si las cuerdas interactúan
fuertemente estas correcciones son
demasiado grandes no permiten afinar el
resultado e incluso con un número
infinito de ellas no podríamos describir
ciertos
fenómenos sin embargo el descubrimiento
de este vínculo entre las dos teorías
permitirá sondear el comportamiento de
estas cuerdas en fuerte interacción
basta con introducir de nuevo la
undécima dimensión que habíamos
comprimido en un círculo añadiendo esta
dimensión conseguiremos Describir el
universo de la teoría 2a Pero esta vez
para cuerdas que interactúan
intensamente para describir este régimen
es entonces necesaria una undécima
dimensión de forma similar podemos
compactification
la vez obtenemos una descripción de la
teoría e8 CR e8 y también en este caso
este vínculo entre los dos modelos
permite a los físicos sondear el
comportamiento de las cuerdas que
interactúan fuertemente
poco a poco se van descubriendo más
dualidades si tomamos las teorías 2a y
2b y comprimimos cada una de ellas en un
círculo uno grande y otro pequeño
obtenemos dos mod los diferentes que en
realidad son equivalentes describen el
mismo Universo de dos maneras
diferentes por ejemplo la velocidad de
una cuerda que se mueve en la dimensión
compacta corresponde al número de veces
que da vueltas alrededor de esta
dimensión en la otra
descripción esto se conoce como dualidad
t también vincula las dos teorías
heteróceros dualidad s cuando la
intensidad de las interacciones es débil
por un lado y fuerte por
otro ya hemos visto esta dualidad con la
supergravedad que permite sondear las
interacciones de fuerte intensidad en
dos teorías de supercuerdas
pero también se aplica a los tipos 1 y
so32 o lo que es aún más interesante a
la propia teoría 2b cuando se invierte
la intensidad de las interacciones los
tipos de brana contenidos en la teoría
se convierten unos en otros de modo que
se encuentra el mismo modelo que al
principio en pocos años los
investigadores descubrieron numerosas
dualidades que unían todas estas
teorías gracias a estas dualidades los
cálculos tediosos pueden simplificarse
cambiando el
modelo Este descubrimiento ha permitido
estudiar fenómenos antes inaccesibles y
descubrir por ejemplo que la entropía de
los agujeros negros la cantidad de
información que contienen puede
calcularse contando las cuerdas atadas a
ellos los resultados concuerdan
perfectamente con las fórmulas de
radiación de
Hawking conducirá también al
descubrimiento de otra dualidad
fascinante la correspondencia ads cft
según la cual ciertos universos pueden
describirse como hologramas de su
[Música]
superficie en
1995 witen propuso que podría existir
una única teoría fundamental de las que
las cinco versiones de las supercuerdas
y la supergravedad de 11 dimensiones
solo serían
aproximaciones más bien como mapas de un
paisaje aún desconocido estas seis
teorías serían descripciones parciales y
las dualidades que las vinculan
indicarían que se solapan para describir
las mismas zonas witen llamó a este
modelo teoría m un nombre misterioso
para una teoría Igualmente Misteriosa
tanto si la llamaba membrana o matriz
dejaba en manos de futuros
investigadores que la entenderían mejor
la decisión sobre su
significado a gran escala la te tea m
describiría un mundo supers simétrico de
11 dimensiones que contiene
branas pero a escala fundamental su
formalismo sigue siendo un misterio
podría resultar ser una descripción
completamente nueva del
universo ya hay intentos de formalizar
como el modelo matricial
bfs según el cual el espaciotiempo y las
cuerdas surgirían de una descripción
abstracta pero esta investigación está
resultando
compleja en la actualidad como todas las
propuestas de gravedad cuántica la
teoría m no está respaldada por ninguna
prueba
experimental como otras teorías Acepta
una gran variedad de contenidos y
geometrías del espacio-tiempo y aún no
sabemos cuál corresponde a nuestro
universo al igual que no podemos sondear
la geometría de nuestro espacio-tiempo a
gran escala tampoco podemos hacerlo la
escala fundamental por el
momento sin embargo sigue siendo la
principal candidata a una teoría del
todo que unifique la gravedad y el
modelo estándar para muchos
investigadores la teoría es elegante y
prometedora ya que predice la existencia
de la gravedad sin tener que agregarla
al modelo ha tenido numerosas
repercusiones tanto en física como en
matemáticas al mismo tiempo sean han
desarrollado otras teorías como la
gravedad cuántica de bules la
triangulación dinámica causal y la
seguridad asintótica que también
intentan formular la gravedad
cuántica Cuál de estos modelos nos
permitirá comprender el universo quién
sabe quizás también ellos se
complementen hacia una teoría aún más
[Música]
general